who's the greatest drummer that ever
lived beside yourself Trey who seriously
who is the greatest drummer that ever
lived I mean I'm G to piss off a lot of
people when I say Ringo Star just
because I adore him I love Keith Moon
John bonam buddy and Meg white and Buddy
Rich of course what about uh Ginger
Baker yeah he's good but Ringo is a
surprising answer because people Ringo
wasn't a show booer he didn't like uh
maybe it wasn't the fanciest but he held
the beat and it he played what's
supposed to be played in the song You
Know drummers forget that they're
playing a song Sometimes you know you
think that drummers sometimes have to
show off the drum as opposed to
supporting the song yeah I think it's
it's probably because we're like hiding
behind the symbols and we kind you know
we don't get to wag our dongs in in
everyone's faces yeah do you ever get
jealous of that do you ever sit there
and go wait [__] I'm back here not I'm
pretty comfy back here I like my little
I got a
table it's sometimes it's hard to it's
hard to keep him back there sometimes I
got to admit that yeah well you know I
think Lars from Metallica does a good
job of like sort of integrating himself
into the band for some reason he's able
to like almost stand up during playing
the drums you know what I mean he's L
has a really unorthodox way of playing
like he's I think he's a really creative
drummer you know I think there's like
the as far as like the metal drummers of
his his even up till now the people that
were influenced by Metallica like I
think that there's something very
studious about the way other people play
but I think that like the way that him
and James Hetfield play together is so
just in lockstep and the way like his
drum fills are completely unique to to
the way Lars plays I I I I really I
really dig the way Lars he's a great
drummer yeah me too he and his energy is
like infectious you know like he he uh
he's like a heavy metal
Muppet